mr. James Earl Jones and I have the  pleasure of presenting the film edit in  the world  and pleasure desmos Cardinale the film  editor is the artist who takes all those  bits and pieces of film splice them  together into a coherent sequence and  leave my close-ups on the floor not  yours mine for making us all look better  in our work we congratulate these  editors for the nominations William  Reynolds  for Hello Dolly Hugh Robertson for  Midnight Cowboy William Lyon and Earl  hurdle for the secret of Santa tutoria  Frederic stank man for they shoot horses  don't they  Francois husband o4z and the winner is  the winner is  Francois spinozzi  well I don't know what what to say just  thank you and I would like to thank  costa-gavras who gave me the chance to  do it